Bonjour salam aleykoum à tous,
on est en direct de énième manifestation à Lyon.
Vous savez,
ça fait des mois que le massacre et le génocide
continuent à Gaza,
aucun gouvernement, ni occidental,
ni arabe, ni musulman ne réagit.
Donc nous, la population civile,
on est obligé de se mobiliser pour les Palestiniens.
Comme on l'avait dit par le passé,
il y a les campagnes de boycott,
il y a les manifestations,
il y a les invocations.
Et là on va avoir 1 occasion en plus
de mettre en avant la cause palestinienne
sur les élections européennes.
Comme on l'avait annoncé avec le dmf,
on a annoncé
officiellement le lancement de la koalition
cri Palestine
avec donc le dmf en France,
les parties au Pays-Bas,
en Belgique, en Suède, en Espagne.
Et on veut faire de cette élection
européenne 1 vitrine
pour la cause palestinienne.
Donc on va organiser des meetings,
on aura certainement 1 bus
qui fera 1 Tour de France
pour porter la cause palestinienne.
Donc il faut profiter de cette élection pour en parler
et surtout n'oubliez pas au moment des élections
de sanctionner ceux qui n'ont rien dit ou qui ont été
complices des crimes Israéliens
et votez pour ceux qui défendent
la cause palestinienne.
Et le dmf bien évidemment, fera partie
de de ces gens-là.
Voilà, je vous remercie et je vous dis à bientôt